pass interference replay review was
adopted in 2019 on a one-year only basis
so now owners will have to decide what
to do for 2020 do you bring it back to
you do something else what do you do to
avoid the worst case scenario which we
saw play out in the 2018 NFC
Championship Game Rich McKay the
competition Committee Chairman who a
year ago was a strong proponent of doing
nothing in the aftermath of Ram Saints
and he was coerced otherwise once the
league meetings came around he told mark
masky The Washington Post I think we all
saw the frustration that we had during
the year regarding replay review of past
interference I do think it began to get
better but I want to see it all in the
total picture and not deal from emotion
McKay also said it's too early to say
whether replay review for pass
interference will or should be retained
Peter you've got an idea for what they
should do I've got some ideas for what
they should do let's hear what what your
take is on what the league should do
when they gather in March for the annual
meeting at which they'll decide whether
or not to continue with replay review
for pass interference well Mike since
the end of the year one of my pet
questions to people around the league at
all levels of football what should
happen with this pass interference rule
and as and as the listeners of viewers
will remember all right a year ago in
March the NFL owners voted 31 to 1 to
put in this system of having plays
called on the field pass interference
plays called on the field and then not
called on the field both replay
reviewable and I've asked people since
the end of the year since it was not
called the way that it was written in a
rule the NFL basically made it be you've
got to get absolutely mugged
that is three seconds before the ball
gets there for us to even consider it
that's what it became and so I've asked
people all over the league what do you
think of this Mike I got to tell you
something it needs a 3/4 majority vote
to be reinstituted for the 2020 season I
haven't found I found one person who
said we'll get the kinks out and I bet
have the other ten people I've talked to
about this everyone else said either we
got to get rid of it
it's got it's got to have major surgery
or it just doesn't work so I don't think
there's any way it's gonna pass muster
in March so my idea is this
if owners and I actually think this
should happen but if owners if coaches
if teams want to have that failsafe
which is the Saints Rams Nickell Roby
Coleman Tommy Lee Lewis failsafe if you
want to have that in pick a number of
minutes at the end of the game three
five two and just say for the last let's
say three minutes of a game New York or
the replay official upstairs or or ask I
judge what whatever it is that person or
if it's New York those people will be in
charge of basically saying hold on we
got a look at this play and so have that
emergency you know pull rope in case of
emergency person in place and call it in
the last three minutes of a game but
don't populate the first X number of
minutes of the game 55 57 with this call
I got a simpler solution you want to
hear it yep bring back Dean Blandino
because if you bring back if look and
this is nothing against that were ever
on but I don't think it's controversial
for us to say that there are aspects of
the replay review supervision that
escaped him at times and that he's not
necessarily suited for that portion of
the job he can run the officiating he
can supervise the officials but I think
they need to bring back Dean Blandino to
be the guy who's in charge of replay
review and who is the public face and
voice of what is the most critical job
for the NFL during football season more
important than the Commissioner job in
Blandino has proven he can do it before
I would get rid of replay review for
pass interference cuz once it's gone
it's very hard to bring it back it's not
impossible they once got rid of replay
review altogether and then brought it
back years later but I think you make a
run at bringing back Blandino and I know
there are people of influence in the
league who want land II know back I
think if you have the right person to
implement this thing it could still work
I think that's the
first question they need to ask
themselves before they move on to other
alternatives Mike I don't think bringing
Dean Blandino I think that sounds good
oh now we get a really good and
extraordinarily competent guy in place
Mike they're still gonna be ticky tack
bang bang plays in pass interference and
the whole question is if you allow all
these reviews to go by the letter of the
law the game is going to be is gonna
have a lot more of these reviews and
that's one thing the NFL doesn't want to
have it I'm not saying you shouldn't
want to get every play right I get it
but I think you're looking for a panacea
the Dean blandina would bring and he
wouldn't bring it there are just some
plays that are too close and you can't
tell but if he knows how to apply the
standard it is the panacea what we
bagged with already know it is
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports